des débuts de la modernité les femmes
seront exclus de ce processus lui-même
et donc les femmes pour devoir lutter au
moins pendant deux siècles elles luttent
encore et cette lutte c'est une lutte
moi que je conçois comme une hutte en
spirale c'est à dire on commence par
l'extérieur pour aller de plus en plus
vers le coeur du problème des centres
aucun du mal la première étape la
l'extériorité de la spirale qu'est ce
que c'est l'extériorité de la spirale
c'est le droit la lutte pour les trois
et ça n'a pas été facile
on pensait encore qu'en france au sortir
de la seconde guerre mondiale les femmes
n'avaient pas le droit de vote et de
l'avenir mais après ça s'est arrangé
pour ça c'est pas roulé puisque encore
jusqu'en 1900 1900 combien 1990 en
france je ne marque pas de sociétés qui
seraient des sociétés donc en 1990 il a
fallu attendre 1990 pour que la cour de
cassation française reconnaisse qu'il
pouvait y avoir vous pouvez qu'avoir
viol entrée 10
autrement dit qu'une femme une fois
mariés pouvaient refuser son
consentement sexuel dont s'était pas
reconnue neuf datant de 1990 en france
c'est pas ailleurs dans des pays
exotiques extraordinaire il a fallu se
battre pour obtenir juste l'aspect
extérieur les droits abstrait cette
égalité mais ça n'a pas suffi ensuite
pour avoir des on allait droit mais il
faut appliquer ces trois appliquer ces
droits qu'est ce que c'est déjà pas mal
d'être que ce soit reconnue appliquer
les droits c'est l'égalité économique
enfin pas l'égalité n'est pas
l'égalitarisme
mais le fait à compétence égale à
travail égal on est en revenu égal et
alors là ça a été une lutte encore plus
acharnée et à venir en dit encore parce
que c'est un beau intérieur de la
spirale avoir ça résiste un peu plus et
puis il reste le terminer le dernier
niveau
c'est ce que j'appelle aussi l'oeil du
cyclone parce que c'est ce qui a l'air
d'être silencieux c'est une zone ont
ressenti mans s'est pas très bien ce que
c'est on n'en parle pas on évite d'en
parler comme dans l'oeil du cyclone
silencieux mais c'est ça toute l'énergie
claude c'est dans la ville et bien
linguistique l'aude il est directement
remis en cause
je crois pour la première fois avec
cette extension par le hashtag guitou
balance conforme du tce choses là mais
qu'est ce que c'est
ces deux jeunes c'est la souveraineté
des femmes sur leur propre corps ah oui
parce que la liberté économique
c'est une chose mais c'est bien la
liberté endroit reconnu c'est quelque
chose aussi
c'est très bien mais la première des
libertés c'est
la liberté sur son propre corps c'est à
dire lusage de son propre corps et c'est
très exactement le message d'habitants
c'est une étonnant c'est que depuis sept
ou huit mois on parle d'à peu près tout
et n'importe quoi dans les médias à
propos de ce sujet alain thinet est-ce
qu'on va trop loin
est-ce qu'on va pas assez loin excusez
moi du peu
si l'illégalité la plus profonde
puissante l'ombre universel de toute
l'histoire de l'humanité
et si maintenant on irait trop loin ça
serait hop on pouvait pas flirter
tranquillement en version culture
française mais il n'y a aucun message
sur les meilleurs témoignages dans la
shta gi joe qui demandent moins de flirt
qui demande
on ne se rapproche pas qu'ils demandent
même qu'on ne se touchent pas que qui à
part du contact nos pages
c'est pas du tout remise en cause du
flirt pas du tout encore de la drague
entre guillemets c'est plutôt le
contraire c'est même plutôt contraire je
ne la demande de mythos si on lit parce
que mme emerson denise dé san un
problème c'est bien que dans les médias
tout le monde est persuadé de savoir ce
qu'il ya dedans mais c'est une demande
d'extension de la liberté sexuelle a eu
toute limitation avec un petit détail
réciproque
ah non là ça devient effectivement là
c'est plus exactement pareil quand on
dit récit planté pas l'égalité aux
adresses et la réciprocité réciprocité
dans le rapport direct au corps dans le
rapport direct au corps
ça veut dire que les hommes que les
femmes aient droit
concrètement à jouir de leur corps au
même niveau sur le même plan jean bonomo
de jouissance à dessein parce que le mot
jouissance il signifie à la fois
l'orgasme au sens physique physiologique
du terme qui pendant des millénaires a
été un scandale l'orgasme féminin et
donc de la masturbation féminine donc
l'autonomie de la jouissance du corps
des femmes donc j'entends jouissant de
notre sens ma maison tu en jouissance au
sens de ski très légèrement plus loin
dans la spirale économiquement c'est à
dire la jouissance au sens notarial au
sens du droit civil la jouissance de la
propriété parce que la jouissance de la
propriété un extérieur de swan est
directement liée donc la jouissance du
monde à la première les licences qui la
jouissance de son corps sur commence par
unimer les femmes d'emblée au niveau du
corps c'est que nous on leur reconnaît
qu une jouissance civile extérieur sur
le plan la mobilité qui pâtissent la
jouissance des droits si la licence des
droits civiques la jouissance politique
ténois politique c'est dans la
continuité
au fond on pourrait même dire que ce
qu'on produit les sociétés humaines
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est une négation
systématique de la jouissance des femmes
à la barre de la barre de la laddh sur
le plan physique qui a conduit à leur
milieu ou d'autres formes de jeu
steelandt qu'ils soient civils qu'ils
soient politiques donc vous comprenez
création revient mon histoire de spirale
que si vous dites que vous l'avez abordé
des droits politiques droits de vote
extériorité et puis un peu plus à
l'intérieur des droits économiques
si vous accordez pas l'endroit de man
qui est la base même de l'inégalité sur
laquelle font des inégalités économiques
et unités politique c'est comme si vous
ne leur accorder rien à rien mais c'est
comme si au fond vous ne reconnaissiez
pas complètement c'est à dire que vous
ne connaissez pas la barre de ce qui
constitue la justification de cette idée
qualité et c'est très exactement ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui avec la résistance
avec le fait de faire comme si on
parlait d'autre chose alors en france on
dire repas plus nous voir leurs têtes
une ineptie totale
encore une fois aucune femme les
millions des moniales de demandes sortir
à si la dénonciation de régime
est ce que quelqu'un est allé voir ce
qu'il y avait le nom c'était la
dénonciation tout déluge avec quelques
noms aujourd'hui le principe c'est
l'anonymat
et c'est la dénonciation par individuel
c'est la dénonciation d'un multitude des
situations qui finissent par constituer
la situation des femmes dans le rapport
direct au corps alors certains disent
oui mais bon gars mais j'aurais pu s'en
rendre compte plutôt pourquoi s'est elle
porte plainte plus tard etc mais parce
que midi
devenu un espace de réalisation au sens
de rendre réel des situations justement
qui paraissait encore naturel chez
certaines jeunes femmes et jeunes filles
un certain moment de leur vie et donc en
lisant le témoignage d'autres viendra
bel réalise elle réalise pour les a
forcées elles réalisent qu'elles ont
fait des toiles de mer et se sont laissé
pénétrer sanguinet et de sa fille se
disent tiens je l'avais une ivg fait
semblant parce que j'avais l'impression
d'être une allumeuse assortie d'une
boîte de nuit où après une fête est donc
une sorte de pression et j'ai succombé à
cette pression je me suis pas rendu
compte
c'est ça la fameuse hongrie mais la zone
grise est extrêmement important parce
que c'est la situation alors des états
unis on va dire il faudrait plus de ces
récation femmes
moi je suis pro d'université qui vit une
partie de mon temps aux états unis il
faut laisser la porte ouverte quand on
accueille dans son bureau de jeu de vie
et c'est là aussi mauvaise réponse
il n'y a pas de demande de ce type dormi
tout c'est un mouvement social radical
mais pas extrêmes
ça veut dire que il est radical parce
que au sens étymologique il prend les
choses à la racine donc ça fait mal
d'arracher les préjugés d'arracher
toutes ses représentations
mais c'est à l'extrême au centre c'est
extrêmement responsable ce n'est pas un
désir de vengeance c'est le désir de
vivre avec les hommes dans cette
réciprocité mais c'est pas facile parce
que ça
suppose de revenir en arrière descente
au coeur du même les descentes au coeur
du match historique
j'allais dire même paléoanthropologie
sur qu'est-ce qui a bien pu se passer
qu'est ce que c'est un corps d'homme
qu'est ce que c'est un corps de femme
qu'est ce que c'est surtout comme tant
de femmes dans les yeux quand même
encore aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle
et ça remonte beaucoup parce que
l'inégalité est tout le temps à partir
du corps commence à partir du pour vous
le regardez dans toutes les religions
pas parce que ce sont des religions
c'est parce que c'est le coeur de la
culture
historiquement c'est la voir donc
eve sorti la côte d'adam
vous avez mené d autres gens debout dit
qu'ils supposent être égalitaire vous
pouvez pas atteindre les veines dans un
corps de femme
d'abord c'est un garde et on se
réincarner chanel sort du corps toujours
cette inégalité de base toujours cette
idée j'ai platon les grands philosophes
les femmes ont un corps qui est un corps
diminué chez aristote
ça laisse des deux représentations
alors certains pourraient dire oui mais
c'est peut-être vrai c'est l'argument
naturalisme elles sont quand même moins
forte les hommes physiquement et cetera
vous avez des études paléoanthropologie
aujourd'hui qui ne sont pas du tout tiré
par les cheveux et qui vous montrent que
depuis 750 bilan ou des mois elias est
censé propre bilan aux morts de ce qu'on
appelle le président vertaviens dans les
premières sociétés de chasseurs
cueilleurs pendant des centaines de
milliers d'années
les femmes ont été exclus de la
nourriture gardait ce qui fait qu'elles
étaient déficientes en protéines et que
ça a aussi construit particulièrement
longs moments de la parturition hésiter
privé des deux protéines ce qui fait que
l ont progressivement lui encore qui
était
subi ce que françoise héritier à peine
une pression évolutive qui s'est traduit
par un corps un peu plus chétifs plus
étroit plus petit et ce qui est étonnant
c'est que ce corps plus petit plus des
trois péchés tiff va devenir plus jolie
dans les yeux les hommes c'est-à-dire
plaisir d'en construire la
représentation viril à partir de cette
étroitesse c'est à dire ceux qui
pouvaient être présentée comme une
pression une imposition va être vu comme
quelque chose to go donc des qualités
féminines au néolithique
ça va se transformer en corps et
j'allais dire c'est au nom mythique ça
devenir le plus grand au néolithique va
se constituer ce que j'appelle le
capitalisme sexuel dans lequel nous
vivons encore qu'est ce que ça veut dire
capitalisme ou sexuelles
qu'est ce que je veux dire par là je
veux dire que la virilité elle même le
sens même d'être un homme donc d'être
vertueux même étymologie vite hommes
vertus héroïsme va se construire par
l'accumulation de la possession des
femmes et par possession des femmes
progressivement sa d'entrer dans la
langue ça veut dire une part que je
possède six femmes que je prends c'est à
dire une femme avec qui je vais amour
que je pénètre et il va y avoir cette
idée que lorsque je pénètre une femme je
lui prends quelque chose il part
comprennent me donne quelque chose
d'abord parce que j'en jouis au sens
physiologie du derrière lui jean louis
au sens civil en lui imposant des
activités à toute une série de choses
qu'elle doit faire et pas moi et ça me
parle toujours du corps et donc d'avoir
une lutte pour 7
une chance qui va constituer la virilité
les garçons vont être éduqués pour ça
d'ailleurs
les initiations dans les plus anciennes
sociétés sont des initiations qui sont
les ancêtres dans la compétition
rousseau mesure où les hommes se mesure
pour dire à quel point ils sont fort
plus fort plus capable de prendre des
femmes
cette structure elle se maintiendra tout
au long du xxème siècle un le chef de
service en médecine avec des infirmières
combien de tirs entre entre le pilote de
ligne avec willy l'ondé de l'air etc
on a la même structure non mais c'est
une structure imaginaire qui est
extrêmement intéressante
ça veut dire que sur le fond les femmes
en devenir ce qu'on appelle en économie
des biens fongible désolé de parler si
directement des bien fragile ça veut
dire simplement des biens qui perd près
de la valeur à usage d'où la
valorisation de la virginité et d'où le
rapport qui existe encore aujourd'hui
des femmes qui vont nier parce qu'elles
ont ils y ont été entraînés dès
l'enfance
encore aujourd'hui le petit moine car
justement élite où c'est le renversement
ça elles ont été éduqués à nier leur
propre jouissance mais à se représenter
elles-mêmes leur corps comme le capital
qu'elle négocie qui va pouvoir faire
jouir un homme
donc si même elles ont envie
éventuellement de coucher tout de suite
avec un homme elle pour faire comme si
peut-être pas pas tout de suite parce
qu'elles sont peut-être quelque chose à
négocier parce que dans la structure
inconsciente elle son sentiment qu'elle
perdrait quelque chose parce qu'on dit
qu'une femme perd sa virginité
alors qu un homme gagne en vérité donc
pouvoir être l'agilité pas se construire
si je puis dire sur le dos n'est pas de
cette manière là c'est ça le capitalisme
sexuelle qui est d'ailleurs certains
entrepreneurs ont montré que c'était une
des causes du développement du
capitalisme dans sa version économique
parce que la fin cette première forme
d'appropriation var engendrer d'autres
formes d'appropriation pour sécuriser sa
propriété qui sera emprunté devant les
femmes vont tout le temps être en
retrait affaibli fragilisé et cette
fragilité très féminine c'est ce qu'on
va après le charme et c'est ce qui va
construire nos fantasmes nos entames de
tonio on trouve dans le mytho qui durera
sûrement le mythe du prince charmant
c'est lui qui donne son statut et la
femme qu'il a son corps pour capitale
comme capitale et il l'a réveil elle
dort on la belle au bois dormant il
n'arrivait et ils n'arrivent elles il a
révélé il arrive n est là dessus c'est
tout à fait ordinateur est il arrivé n'a
elle-même et de bain que d'accepter
même si même pas qu'elle ne peut
qu'accepter c'est que l'idée même
qu'elle puisse être violée dans un sens
n'a pas le sens puisqu'elle ne pas que
accepté vouloir et désiré le désir de
l'homme qui lui prenait jusqu'à frey qui
nous disait que des femmes n'avaient pas
de limite au positive c'est une ineptie
c'est à dire que même lorsqu'elle avait
du désir c'était un désir tout le temps
qu'ils réagissaient aux désirs des
hommes donc réactif donc dégainé une
question immédiatement qui se pose
pourquoi cet acharnement à vouloir
diminuer les femmes
si les hommes sont si sûrs de leur
pouvoir ça c'est
problème quand on y réfléchit pourquoi à
la base vouloir obsessionnellement faire
en fait on a un début de réponse
lorsqu'on regarde la définition de ce
qu'est une femme par exemple au
moyen-age de ce que c'est une femme qui
refuse d'être possédé dominé et pénétrer
ostensiblement à un homme à partir d'un
certain âge dont vous allez vraiment mon
âge de se reproduire et v personnes
érotique
cette aide est érotique elle refuse de
se marier elle refuse d'entrer dans les
ordres et donc il ne reste plus qu'un
statut elle devient sorcière
automatiquement la définition d'une
sorcière c'est une femme qui à partir
d'un certain âge se refuse refuse le
mariage est refusée au 19e siècle on
appellera ça une hystérique construit à
partir de hystérique qui veut dire
utérus aux 27 chefs progressivement on
appellera ça une
mais bien commun entre les trois la
sorcière l'hystérie et la le
point commun c'est que c'est la croyance
qu'une femme qui n'est pas contrôlée ni
par le mariage de par les ordis par la
religion dont des femmes qui jouirait de
façon autonome et immédiatement une
superpuissance qui met en péril les
autres
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une sorcière la
définition d'une sorcière c'est
maintenant quel temps il ya des pouvoirs
donc du pouvoir dont une puissance qu'on
peut pas contrôler qu'on ne peut pas
limiter l'hystérique c'était une femme
qui avait une capacité jouissance al
ihsan alors que les hommes se
représenter
ayant sont représentés comme une
incapacité de jouissance médicalement
limité de faire l'amour une fois deux
fois trois fois
après c'est vraiment difficile alors
qu'une femme en théorie dans cette
histoire de tiberi elle pouvait jouir
juste à se rendre au top c'est aussi
l'image qu'on avait de la sorcière
ça veut dire quelqu'un qui aurait une
puissance infinie
c'est quoi si le miroir négatif de l'
angoisse la plus fondamentale des hommes
le sentiment d'impuissance
c'est quand même étonnant que le mot
même d'un puits sort qui veut juste de
dire ne pas avoir de pouvoir se rapporte
directement immédiatement encore une
fois pas quoi au corps et pas n'importe
quoi dans le corps juste à sète au moins
de l'incapacité à avoir une érection
sens physique du terme devant un corps
de femme donc vers des questions
aujourd'hui c'est de dire comment s'en
sortir et c'est la question qui posait
des questions tout à fait responsable
parce que les hommes cherchent à s'en
sortir
au début ils ont nié la jouissance des
femmes ensuite dix neuvième siècle ils
l'ont contrôlé auprès de guînes à
contrôler sa vie stérilisation et
maintenant enfin d'après années 70 ça
les a tous les frais liés et donc ils
sauront qu'ils ont construit un autre
mythe le fait qu' il ne pouvait plus
payer
on doit la contrôler et nous quittons la
croque et donc c'est la reconstitution
du mâle viril qui se dit de il provoque
la jouissance il provoque l'organe c'est
lui le maître l'organe donc ça ça à
nouveau s'arrêter intériorisée par
on ne parle beaucoup de femmes qui
savent aujourd'hui comment faire
semblant par rapport à l'agglo désir de
virilisation nouvelle mouture des hommes
mais ça aussi ça doit être dépassé
comment s'en sortir
est-ce qu'on vous pouvez est ce qu'il
faudrait pour sortir en éliminant la
différence entre le féminin et masculin
alors qu'effectivement le féminin a été
construit par l'écrasement de la
virilité est la définition même du
féminin et et concevoir des fêtes je
crois que c'est pas possible
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]